the return and reunion of 31 children
with their families is a victory for
careful and complicated negotiations to
secure their release in many cases held
against their will for months child
protection workers believe their stories
will help prove the international
Criminal Court's case against Russian
President Vladimir Putin and his
children's rights commissioner Maria
alvova belova
how were they deported what happened in
their camps how they were relocated
because it's kidnapping all of this it
is destroying the Ukrainian identity it
is a war crime and genocide
sixteen-year-old Vitale was sent with
his parents consent to a Russian Health
Camp in October last year
it was meant to be a two-week break from
the hardships of occupied her son it
turned into a six-month ordeal before
Vitale finally saw his family again in
March
the first two weeks were normal but
after three weeks I started to look for
every possibility to go home
Vitale says he was among more than 800
Ukrainian children at just one Camp
homesick often scared and at times he
says placed in a detention cell for days
as punishment for transgressions
they fed his porridge without salt and
sugar three times a day every evening
they spoke to us about politics they
would say Russia is a powerful country
and Ukraine is a terrorist one
the international criminal court says
it's identified hundreds of cases of
children allegedly forcibly taken from
Care Homes and orphanages in Ukraine
deported it says with the intention of
permanently removing them from their
country of birth that's a violation of
the Geneva Convention it says and a war
crime
Ukraine insists the practice is much
wider saying it's identified more than
nineteen and a half thousand cases of
forced deportations including many like
Vitale taken with parental permission
under false pretenses instead enduring
months of indoctrination and propaganda
Daria casyanova has helped reunite 84
children with their families by
providing the Russians with proof of
legal guardianship I put to her a video
that Russia's children's commissioner
recently showed to U.N security Council
Members it purports to show Happy
Ukrainian children some receiving
Medical Care others placed in foster
care
these pictures of children living in
safety is such a manipulation using
children as objects not subject to
rights trying to construct a different
reality
Russia admits to the removal of 2 000
Ukrainian children from occupied areas
in the conflict Zone but presents it as
a humanitarian effort the ICC calls it a
war crime and one Ukraine says is taking
place on a far bigger scale in plain
sight Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Kiev